et oui c'est ainsi que s'appellera le
nouveau pimkie edouard molinaro tourne
actuellement à montpellier c'est un
titre un peu olé olé mais vous allez
voir qu'en l'occurrence il veut bien
dire ce qu'il veut dire
un tueur est engagée pour supprimer le
témoin gênant d'un procès en monture
consciencieux et s'efforce de passer
inaperçu réservant en face du palais de
justice une chambre discrète dans un
hôtel discret mais dans la chambre
voisine se trouve un homme qui va tout
gâcher il a des problèmes sentimentaux
cet homme là et il veut ce tuer en
sautant par la fenêtre de sa chambre
si bien que petit à petit la tension des
journalistes et les policiers mobilisés
devant le palais de justice pour le
procès va se porter sur lui et bientôt
sur son voisin le tueur qui n'en
demandait pas tant et pour cause
en définitive une histoire me policière
mi comique ou l'enquiquiner s'appelle
lino ventura et l'anc et inner jacques
brel la mer du nord au dernier des reins
ran
et des vagues de dunes pour arrêter
vagues et de vagues aussi que les maris
dépasse et qui ont à jamais le coeur
mary bale vous savez jacquerie c'est
quelqu'un de très pudique n'aime pas
beaucoup parler de lui c'est très
difficile et c'est quelqu'un qui laisse
les choses derrière lui c'est quelqu'un
qui regarde qui regarde devant
il a abandonné le métier de chanteur
pour devenir comme comédien il a
abandonné où ils abandonnent le métier
de comédien pour devenir metteur en
scène il abandonnera le métier de
metteur en scène peut devenir pilote
qu'est-ce qui sera après avoir été
pilote que ce navigateur j'en sais rien
malige était au bout de ce que je
pouvais faire sincèrement à un moment je
me suis arrêté c'est le moment où je
pensais que je n'avais plus qu'à je
n'avais plus rien de ta part tend à dire
je n'avais plus qu'à me répéter
peut-être une copie de balès à jour n'a
pas supporté
e
nos vampires a aussi de ce quelqu'un de
extrêmement ludique et très difficile à
pénétrer ce qu'il faut pas facilement
je pense que quelqu'un dont il faut
essayer d'obtenir de m'irriter l'amitié
et après ça il faut prend là on aura
mais devant soi quelqu'un de 2,13 et
relire dans les rapports humains de très
détendu très facile neurologue de lui et
je pense être son ami c'est à moi de
je n'ai pas les qualités
beaucoup lino pour sa tendresse pour sa
pudeur et pour sa tendresse et le
restant je sais pas comment ni les les
hommes se parlent pas entre eux ce sont
les femmes qui caquettent d'entre elles
en général pour ce bien et les amis sont
pas beaucoup se disent pas grand-chose
mesure
j'aime bien ligne rouge coco lido
c'est tout normalement il aurait agressé
par son poitrail et c'est tout sauf
quand ça que ce serait comme à l'aller
sur le divan
c'est toujours comme ça se fait
avant